У комедійному серіалі "Слуга народу" Володимир Зеленський
зіграв вчителя історії, який раптово став президентом.
У реальному житті актор - також для багатьох раптово -
отримав найбільше голосів у першому турі
президентських виборів. Чому ж українці
ще до виборів збиралися голосувати за Зеленського?
54% українців, опитаних Київським міжнародним інститутом соціології,
кажуть: їм імпонує, що Зеленський – людина не з системи,
нове обличчя в українській політиці.
І лише 6% сподобалося, як він зіграв президента
в серіалі. За словами директора інституту
Володимира Паніотто, за 15 років студія "Квартал 95" Зеленського
стала провідним сатиричним шоу в Україні.
- Коли дивишся, як вони глузують з політиків,
причому з усіх політиків,
і навіть із того ж Коломойського
на каналі, на якого вони працюють, то
складається враження, що вони, по-перше, дуже добре в цій політиці розбираються,
а по-друге, це накладається дуже добре на
загальну низьку довіру до політиків.
"Квартал 95" сформував ціле покоління українців,
які дізнавалися про політику тільки з гумористичних шоу,
вважає медіаекспертка Діана Дуцик. А на додачу до цього
згодом з'явився серіал "Слуга народу".
- Ця відомість (Зеленського - Ред.) створювалася протягом багатьох років.
Не протягом останніх виборчих місяців
або навіть не протягом останнього року.
І звісно, що просто команда Зеленського і ті сили -
я не побоюся цього слова - олігархічні, -
які зробили ставку на Зеленського, цим скористалися.
Тобто вони це використали і зараз
країна стала заручником цієї історії.
Багато хто вважає Зеленського ставлеником
українського бізнесмена Ігоря Коломойського,
олігарха й опонента чинного президента Петра Порошенка.
Саме канал Коломойського транслював серіал "Слуга народу".
Проте політичний експерт Володимир Фесенко
не вважає Зеленського маріонеткою олігарха.
Щоправда, Фесенко не певен, чи зможе Зеленський
самотужки побороти корупцію в українській владі.
Навіть якщо захоче.
- Зеленський та його серіал сформулювали
популярний політичний міф, про те, що лише людина з народу,
не з системи, може зламати цю систему. Це ілюзія.
Один, із невеликою командою зламати систему він не зможе.
Зеленському доведеться приготуватися
до величезного психологічного тиску в разі перемоги,
ділиться своїм досвідом Йон  Гнар - комік та екс-мер
столиці Ісландії Рейк'явіка. На цій посаді йому
довелося витримати відкриту ворожнечу з боку колег-політиків.
- Я знаю історію Зеленського, якийсь час я стежив за її розвитком.
Його історія надихає і він також не один,
навколо нього є група людей, які його підтримують.
Це цілий рух. Проте мені здається, для нього
це небезпечна ситуація. Люди, з якими свого часу
мав справу я, були безжальними та вульгарними.
А в його випадку він матиме справу зі значно серйознішими людьми.
Багатьом українцям герой серіалу "Слуга народу"
нагадує образ самого Володимира Зеленського.
Щоправда, вже зараз видно разючі відмінності
між вчителем Голобородьком та переможцем першого туру виборів.
Володимир Зеленський, до прикладу,
приїжджає на роботу на дорогому авто з охороною,
а не на велосипеді. І навряд чи пересяде на нього,
якщо стане президентом.